This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. Good morning! Morning! Good morning! Oh, and in case I don't see you. Good afternoon, good evening and good night. In the 1998 movie, The Truman Show, an insurance adjuster slowly discovers
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹坦。大家早上好！早啊！大家早上好！哦，以防我再也见不到你们。祝你下午好，傍晚好，晚安。在1998年的电影《楚门的世界》中，一名保险理赔员慢慢发现
that his entire life is a sham. His wife, his best friend, his neighbors, they're all actors, playing roles in a reality show conceived by a mad television producer. When he figures this out, Truman Burbank starts dreaming about escape, but he finds he's trapped, even the traffic seems coordinated to prevent him from leaving town. What did every turn beautifully synchronized, don't you agree?
他的一生完全是一个骗局。他的妻子、最好的朋友、邻居们，全都是演员，在一个由疯狂的电视制作人构思的真人秀中扮演角色。当他发现这一点时，楚门·伯班克开始梦想逃离，但他发现自己被困住了，甚至连交通都似乎经过精心编排，以阻止他离开小镇。每一次转弯都配合得天衣无缝，你不觉得吗？
You're blaming me for the traffic? Should I? On today's show, we explore the idea that many of us are living in our own private version of the Truman Show. Unlike the movie, our prisons are of our own making. They are the fictional worlds we create for ourselves on social media. You're kind of curating your life.
你在怪我交通堵塞喽？难道不该怪你吗？在今天的节目中，我们探讨这样一种观点：我们中的许多人正生活在属于自己的私人版《楚门的世界》中。与电影不同的是，我们的监狱是自己建造的。它们是我们自己在社交媒体上为自己创造的虚构世界。你其实是在精心策展你的人生。
Just these very specific moments, the best of the best that you're putting up there, with no context. Today, hundreds of strangers might observe intimate details of your life, just like the viewers who observed Truman's every step in the movie. Truman found that living inside a television set kept him from discovering his real life. Researchers are finding that the curated versions of our lives that we post on Facebook and Instagram have real consequences in our actual lives. You don't need me to tell you that there are positive things about social media too.
只有那些非常特定的时刻，也就是你发布到网上的那些精选之作，却没有任何背景信息。今天，数百名陌生人可能会观察你私生活的方方面面，就像电影中观察楚门一举一动的观众一样。楚门发现，生活在电视机里让他无法发现自己真实的生活。研究人员发现，我们在Facebook和Instagram上发布的经过精心修饰的生活版本，会对我们的现实生活产生真正的影响。不需要我提醒，你也知道社交媒体也有积极的一面。
Millions of people use these sites to connect with friends and family. But there's a cost. As you watch the seemingly idyllic lives of your friends on social media, you may find a little voice pointing out that your vacations are dull by contrast, that your kid never scores the winning goal. That your relationship seemed to be painted in gray while everyone else's seem to be in technicala. Using Facebook make you more comparative. You compare yourself to others more often. You judge yourself am I better or worse than my friends and my happier are they happier and so on. The cost of the lives we invent on social media this week on Hidden Brain. Rachel Leonard is a free spirit.
数百万人使用这些网站与朋友和家人保持联系。但这是有代价的。当你看着社交媒体上朋友们看似田园诗般的生活时，你可能会听到一个微小的声音指出，相比之下，你的假期显得很沉闷，你的孩子从来没有进过制胜球。你的感情似乎被涂抹成了灰色，而其他所有人的感情似乎都是全彩的。使用Facebook会让你更喜欢攀比。你更频繁地拿自己和别人作比较。你会在心里评判自己：我比我的朋友们过得好还是差？我开心吗？他们更开心吗？诸如此类。我们本周在《隐藏的大脑》中探讨我们在社交媒体上虚构生活的代价。蕾切尔·伦纳德是一个崇尚自由的人。
In her 20s and 30s, she lived all over the United States. I'm Colorado and upstate New York and I lived in Vermont for a long time and then I was living in Asheville, North Carolina. And she traveled all over the world. She met lots of different people in all these places. To keep in touch with them, she signed up for Facebook. I was traveling in Central America in 2006 and 2007 and I did not have a phone and I was in pre-remote areas I signed up then because I kept meeting all these wonderful people and
在她20多岁和30多岁的时候，她在美国各地生活过。我待过科罗拉多州、纽约州北部，我在佛蒙特州住了很长时间，然后住在北卡罗来纳州的阿什维尔。她游历了世界各地。她在所有这些地方遇到了许多不同的人。为了与他们保持联系，她注册了Facebook。我2006年到2007年在中美洲旅行，当时我没有手机，而且身处较为偏远的地区，我就是在那时注册的，因为我不断遇到所有这些美好的人，
One of the ways to immediately, you know connect with them was to friend them on Facebook The site became an important tool for Rachel to keep in touch with people she'd met on her travels, to share her adventures with friends and family back home. That's actually when I started sharing, like, my travels with other friends, my pictures of my trip. But as much as Rachel loved traveling and felt good about the choices she'd made in her life, other feelings started to sneak up on her. Having Facebook also allowed her to see what everyone else was up to, while she was back packing in Central America,
而立即与他们建立联系的方法之一，你知道的，就是在Facebook上加他们为好友。该网站成为蕾切尔与她在旅行中结识的人保持联系、与家乡的朋友和家人分享她的冒险经历的重要工具。实际上，也就是在那时我开始分享我的旅行，比如与其他朋友分享我的旅行照片。但尽管蕾切尔热爱旅行，并对自己在生活中做出的选择感到满意，其他的感觉还是开始悄然向她袭来。拥有Facebook也让她得以看到其他人在忙些什么，而当时她正在中美洲背包旅行，
or moving from one city to another. You know, everybody's getting married, some people have one child, some people have two children. All my friends have these high-power jobs, and they own houses, and all of these things. These feelings were at the back of her mind a few years later, when she met a guy, and decided to start a relationship. I met him and I had been planning to leave the country and go to Southeast Asia to teach and I met him
或者从一个城市搬到另一个城市。你知道的，每个人都在结婚，有些人有了一个孩子，有些人有了两个孩子。我所有的朋友都有高薪工作，他们拥有房子，诸如此类。几年后，当她遇到一个男生并决定开始一段恋爱关系时，这些感觉依然盘旋在她的脑海深处。我遇到了他，我原本计划离开这个国家去东南亚教书，我是在
in December and I was supposed to leave in June and I didn't go. Her new boyfriend asked her to stay with him in Asheville, North Carolina. She wasn't sure it was the right thing to do, but she agreed. It was a turning point in my life in lots of ways because up until then I'd kind of been this free spirit and did what I wanted and traveled a lot and still had that wanderlust. But I was also 33 and kind of looking around and realizing that other people were getting married and having kids and I decided maybe I should try this out. Soon, like so many of her friends, she was posting pictures and details about her happy relationship.
12月遇到他的，我本来应该在6月离开，但我没有去。她的新男友请求她留在北卡罗来纳州的阿什维尔。她不确定这样做是否正确，但她同意了。这在许多方面都是我生活中的一个转折点，因为在此之前，我一直是个崇尚自由的人，做自己想做的事，经常旅行，心里仍然有着那种对远方的渴望。但我也33岁了，开始环顾四周，意识到其他人都在结婚生子，我决定也许我应该尝试一下。很快，就像她身边的许多朋友一样，她开始发布关于她幸福恋情 照片和细节。
We got engaged pretty quickly and you know at this time I'm posting my pictures and posting our hikes. We lived in on, you know, the Blue Ridge Mountains. So we'd have these beautiful hikes and this lovely little town. And of course I'm posting all of this. Her engagement was chronicled. The new house they moved into, the view from the porch. All of it looked beautiful on Facebook. If you looked only from the porch, you could see mountains straight, but if you looked to the left, you could see this huge factory. But of course, I didn't take pictures of the factory because why would you do that? Because Facebook is not a
我们很快就订婚了，你知道的，这时候我在发照片，发我们的远足。我们住在蓝岭山脉。所以我们会有这些美丽的远足和小巧可爱的城镇。当然，我会把这一切都发出去。她的订婚过程被记录了下来。他们搬进去的新房子，从门廊看出去的景色。在Facebook上，这一切看起来都美极了。如果你只从门廊看，你可以直接看到山脉，但如果你向左看，你可以看到这个巨大的工厂。但当然，我没有拍工厂的照片，因为你为什么会做那种事呢？因为Facebook不是一个
place for pictures of ugly factories. It was very taboo not to share positivity. You know, one ever put negative stuff on there. And if they did, people were like, hmm, what's going on with blah, blah, blah. So it was always about being positive and showing your best side and your best moments. Facebook is also not a place for ambivalence. Celebrating triumph, that's welcome. Morning of tragedy, that's okay too. Expressing uncertainty and doubt, not so much.
放丑陋工厂照片的地方。不分享积极向上的内容是非常忌讳的。你知道的，没有人会在上面发消极的东西。如果他们真的发了，大家就会觉得，嗯，某某某怎么了？所以这里永远是关于保持积极、展现你最好的一面和最美好的时刻。Facebook同样也不是一个容纳矛盾心理的地方。庆祝胜利，这是受欢迎的。哀悼悲剧，这也还可以。表达不确定和怀疑，那就大受不经了。
We all intuitively understand the rules. Posts about engagements and babies will receive ravenous applause. News about a grandparent passing away will elicit virtual hugs. But fears about not making rent, marital tensions, hesitations about becoming apparent, those are verboten. Rachel started to feel constricted. The more she posted about her happy life on
我们都凭直觉理解这些规则。关于订婚和宝宝的帖子会获得热烈的掌声。关于祖父母去世的消息会引发虚拟的拥抱。但对于交不起房租的恐惧、婚姻的紧张、对成为父母的犹豫，这些都是禁忌。蕾切尔开始感到受到束缚。她在社交媒体上发布的幸福生活越多，
social media, the greater the disconnect she felt with her real life. The Truman Show she had invented online increasingly felt like a trap. I know now that at the time, while it looked great and it looked right, it didn't really feel right for me, but I think that putting it out there and having my friends say, oh, this looks so wonderful, you look so happy, this is great. It was kind of my way of convincing myself it was. And I'd say that the more things didn't feel great, the more I posted. The golf widened between her real relationship and the Facebook version.
她与真实生活的脱节感就越强。她在线上虚构的《楚门的世界》越来越像是一个陷阱。我现在知道，当时虽然它看起来很棒，看起来很对，但对我来说其实并不对劲，但我认为把它发到网上，让我的朋友们说，哦，这看起来太棒了，你看起来真幸福，这太棒了。这算是我说服自己一切都好的方式吧。而且我想说的是，事情感觉越糟糕，我发的内容就越多。她真实的感情与Facebook版本之间的鸿沟越来越大。
What I'm not posting is that we fought a lot and what seemed to be kind of perfect to other people was not. When the new couple took a trip to Charleston, Rachel says her friends on Facebook only saw the beautiful pictures. She posted photos of the two of them sitting on the beach, drinking mimosas, eating good food. And really, we were fighting that entire time.
我没有发的是我们经常吵架，在其他人看来似乎很完美的事情其实并不完美。当这对新情侣去查尔斯顿旅行时，蕾切尔说她在Facebook上的朋友们只看到了那些美丽的画面。她发布了他们两人坐在海滩上、喝着含羞草鸡尾酒、吃着美食的照片。而实际上，我们那整段旅行都在吵架。
I had actually tried to break up with him. And it was a miserable trip. You know, but I didn't tell anybody that. And I, you know, what I shared was the pictures of us in front of the fountain, or at the aquarium, or eating something delicious, and not that we fought 90% of the time. You're kind of curating your life, just these very specific moments,
我实际上曾试图和他分手。那是一次悲惨的旅行。你知道的，但我没有告诉任何人。而且，你知道的，我分享的是我们在喷泉前、在水族馆里或吃着美味食物的照片，而不是我们90%的时间都在吵架。你其实是在精心策展你的人生，只有那些非常特定的时刻，
the best of the best that you're putting up there, with no context. More and more, Rachel found that she was turning to social media for validation. She wanted confirmation from her social media feed that her life was on track. The more she posted photos of her relationship, the more positive feedback she got. Like… I'm so happy for you. You're finally settling down because I've been chowlling forever and you know, you look
也就是你发布到网上的那些精选之作，却没有任何背景信息。蕾切尔越来越发现，她开始转向社交媒体寻求认可。她希望从自己的社交媒体动态中得到确认，证明自己的人生正走在正轨上。她发布的恋爱照片越多，得到的积极反馈就越多。比如……我为你感到高兴。你终于安定下来了，因为我一直在四处漂泊，你知道的，你们看起来
great, you two look beautiful together. So Rachel convinced herself that this was what she wanted. She had constructed a beautiful version of the truth and now she felt she had to live it. She got married, posted photos of the wedding, she says that she and her husband moved to a new city. They both got jobs, they bought a house, put down roots. You know, on the outside it looked like we had this beautiful new house and he had this great new job and I had this great new job and still things were not good. The house looked beautiful from the outside, but ended up being costly and difficult to fix.
真棒，你们俩看起来很般配。于是蕾切尔说服自己，这就是她想要的。她构建了一个美丽的真相版本，现在她觉得自己必须按照这个版本生活。她结婚了，发布了婚礼照片，她说她和丈夫搬到了一个新城市。他们都找到了工作，买了一座房子，扎下了根。你知道的，从表面上看，我们好像有了这座美丽的房子，他有了这份很棒的新工作，我也有了这份很棒的新工作，然而事情依然很不妙。房子从外面看很漂亮，但结果却花费高昂且难以修补。
Worse than that, Rachel increasingly felt she was with the wrong person. The best way that I can put it is that we were just not suited for each other and I knew it. I think that part of my psyche was just trying to ignore all of these signs that were just this person and I were not, we were not matched well. Rachel quickly got pregnant. She had a difficult pregnancy but again that wasn't something this person and I were not, we were not matched well. Rachel quickly got pregnant. She had a difficult pregnancy, but again, that wasn't something she shared on social media. It was taboo to say that this doesn't feel good, this is really hard, as if you're not
更糟糕的是，蕾切尔越来越觉得自己跟错了人。我能想到的最好说法是，我们就是不适合彼此，而我心里清楚。我觉得我心理的一部分当时只是在试图忽视所有这些迹象，即这个人跟我，我们并不般配。蕾切尔很快就怀孕了。她经历了一次艰难的怀孕，但同样，这不是那种这个人跟我，我们并不般配。蕾切尔很快就怀孕了。她经历了一次艰难的怀孕，但同样，这不是她在社交媒体上分享的事情。说这感觉不好、这真的很艰难是犯忌讳的，就好像你对怀孕不够
grateful that you were pregnant and instead of being able to say those things out loud, I just posted pictures of my growing belly and, you know, cute things and working on the nursery and, you know, things like that, instead of really focusing or sharing what was going on for me internally. The unhappy original felt, the more she posted, and she spent a lot of time looking at other people's posts too. I would just scour other people's lives. I would just, to compare, you know, their happiness against my happiness, you know, and I felt like I shouldn't be feeling the way I was feeling. It seemed like the grass was always greener for everyone else.
感恩一样；与其能够大声说出这些感受，我只是发布了我不断隆起的肚子的照片，还有，你知道的，一些可爱的东西，以及布置婴儿房的照片，你知道的，诸如此类的事情，而不是真正关注或分享我内心真实发生的状况。现实生活越是不幸，她发帖的频率就越高，而且她也花了很多时候看别人的帖子。我只会搜寻别人的生活。我只会去比较，你知道的，他们的幸福和我的幸福，你知道的，我觉得我不应该有我当时的那种草草情绪。在其他人看来，草似乎总是更绿。
Everyone else seemed more successful, happier in their marriages, having more fun with their pregnancies and the early days of motherhood. Eventually, Rachel's marriage fell apart. She said she decided to move back to Cleveland where her family is from, along with her son. And in that moment something happened. You know what was really interesting was when I knew I was moving back to Cleveland, I was trying to kind of put feelers out there because I knew I needed to find a job. And I didn't know how to say it without really saying what was going on. And so I you know posted that my son and I were coming back to Cleveland and we'd be there in June and I was
其他人似乎都更成功，婚姻更幸福，在怀孕和初为人母的日子里过得更有趣。最终，蕾切尔的婚姻破裂了。她说她决定带着儿子搬回老家克利夫兰。就在那一刻，发生了一件事。你知道真正有趣的是什么吗？当我得知我要搬回克利夫兰时，我一直在试探风向，因为我知道我需要找一份工作。而我不知道该怎么说，又不能真正说出发生了什么。所以，你知道的，我发帖说我和我儿子要回克利夫兰了，我们将在6月份到那里，我
looking for some, you know, a new adventure or something like that, put some spin on it. And I got so many private messages from friends of mine who were like, are you guys getting divorced? Blah blah blah and I have been separated for six months or we're getting divorced or I've been divorced for two years I had no idea these are people who I looked at their lives and maybe if I hadn't been so hyper focused on my life I would have maybe noticed that their husbands were not in all the pictures anymore it was eye-opening. Once the spell was broken Rachel realized something. I look at social media differently now.
在寻找一些，你知道的，新的冒险或者诸如此类的事情，给它加点修饰。我收到了来自朋友们的那么多私信，他们问：你们要离婚了吗？巴拉巴拉巴拉，而我已经分居六个月了，或者我们正在离婚，或者我已经离婚两年了。我完全不知道。这些人都是我曾经仰望他们生活的人，也许如果我没有那么高度关注我自己的生活，我可能会注意到他们的丈夫已经不在所有的照片里了。这真是大开眼界。一旦魔法破灭，蕾切尔意识到了一件事。我现在对社交媒体的看法不同了。
In fact, when people are posting a ton of stuff, I'm always kind of like, hmm, I wonder what other story is happening. Not that there has to be doom and gloom and negativity, but there's always another story. There's always something else going on. There's context you could never pick up if you didn't know. There's always something else going on. There's contacts you could never take up if you didn't know. There's always another story. We might know this intellectually, but we still often feel a sense of social comparison when we look at our social media feeds. So it's not that you think that others are happier than you are, but you need to prove yourself to yourself over and over again, and this social comparison
事实上，当人们发布大量东西时，我总是会想：嗯，不知道背后还有什么别的故事在发生。倒不是说一定得有什么世界末日般的阴霾和负面情绪，但总是有另一个故事。总是有别的事情在发生。有些背景信息，如果你不知道，是永远也体会不到的。总是有别的事情在发生。有些背景信息，如果你不了解，是永远也体会不到的。总是有另一个故事。我们理智上可能明白这一点，但当看着自己的社交媒体动态时，我们仍然经常会产生一种社会比较的心态。所以，这倒不是说你认为别人比你更幸福，而是你需要一遍又一遍地向自己证明自己，而这种社会比较
engagement makes you less happy. When we come back, we'll explore how the amount of time you spend on social media can determine how happy you are. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. When I heard Rachel's story, I kept thinking about this tragic irony. She constructed a fake world to keep up with a happy lives of her friends on Facebook. But many of her friends were doing exactly the same thing.
的行为会让你变得不那么快乐。稍后回来，我们将探讨你在社交媒体上花费的时间如何决定你的快乐程度。请不要走开。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹坦。当我听到蕾切尔的故事时，我一直想到这个悲惨的讽刺。她构建了一个虚假的世界，是为了跟上Facebook上朋友们的幸福生活。但她的许多朋友其实也在做着完全相同的事情。
They were trying to keep up with her. Everyone was posting pictures of their beautiful vacation, and no one was saying anything about the fight they'd had during the car trip. Many studies have shown that people who use social media frequently appear to be unhappier than those who don't. But until recently, it was impossible to say whether this was correlation or causation. Do lonely people spend more time on social media in an effort to escape their loneliness or a social media itself causing people to feel isolated. A recent study at Tel Aviv University has provided what may be the first experiment to sort out causation from correlation.
他们试图跟上她的步伐。每个人都在发布自己美好假期的照片，却没有人提及他们在车程中曾发生过争吵。许多研究表明，经常使用社交媒体的人似乎比不使用社交媒体的人更不快乐。但直到最近，人们还无法确定这究竟是相关性还是因果关系。是孤独的人为了逃避孤独而在社交媒体上花费更多时间，还是社交媒体本身导致人们感到孤立？特拉维夫大学最近的一项研究提供了可能是第一项厘清因果关系与相关性的实验。
Yes, so my name is Ohad Barzilei and I am a faculty member at the Colors School of Management in Tel Aviv University. Ohat and his colleagues wanted a test where the spending time on Facebook actually made people feel worse. They happened on what psychologists call a natural experiment. A security firm in Israel decided to restrict the Facebook use of its employees. No one was allowed to use Facebook at all for security reasons. The employees had to delete their accounts if they wanted to continue working for the company. But then, after some time, the firm decided to allow some employees to reopen their accounts. They effectively created two groups, one that used Facebook, one that didn't.
是的，我是奥哈德·巴尔齐莱，我是特拉维夫大学科勒商学院的教员。奥哈德和他的同事们想要测试在Facebook上花费时间是否真的会让人感觉更糟糕。他们偶然发现了一个心理学家所称的自然实验。以色列的一家安全公司决定限制其员工使用Facebook。出于安全原因，任何人都不准使用Facebook。如果员工想继续在公司工作，就必须删除他们的账号。但随后过了一段时间，该公司决定允许部分员工重新开通账号。他们实际上创造了两组人，一组使用Facebook，另一组不使用。
None of these people were choosing which group to be in, so it couldn't be that people who were unhappy were the ones choosing to use Facebook. O'Hardin and his colleagues collected data about the employees, from the time no one was allowed to use Facebook, and a few months after, some employees were allowed to use the social media website. We decided to focus on Facebook effect on social comparison, the perceptions of others' lives and happiness. Social comparison, the very thing Rachel struggled with, looking at other people's lives and trying to figure out whether she measured up.
这些人并不是自己选择加入哪一组的，所以绝不可能是因为不快乐的人才选择使用Facebook。奥哈德和他的同事们收集了关于这些员工的数据，时间跨度从无人被允许使用Facebook的时期，到几个月后部分员工被允许使用该社交媒体网站的时期。我们决定专注于Facebook对社会比较的影响，以及对他人生活和幸福感的看法。社会比较，正是蕾切尔所苦苦挣扎的事情，她看着别人的生活，试图弄清楚自己是否达标。
I would just scour other people's lives. I would just, to compare, you know, their happiness against my happiness. Ohad and his colleagues looked at both groups and they found a few interesting things. Our first finding is that using Facebook make you more comparative. You compare yourself to others more often.
我只会搜寻别人的生活。我只会去比较，你知道的，他们的幸福和我的幸福。奥哈德和他的同事们观察了两组人，他们发现了一些有趣的事情。我们的第一个发现是，使用Facebook会让你更喜欢攀比。你更频繁地拿自己和别人作比较。
You judge yourself, you compare. Am I better or worse than my friends? Am I happier? and my happier? Are they happier and so on? One surprising thing is that the study did not find that people thought others had better lives. They weren't fooled by all the happy vacation and anniversary pictures posted by their friends. We know that people post on Facebook mostly positive things and they under post negative things about their lives. So other studies have argued that users that use Facebook think that their friends have
你会在心里评判自己，你会进行比较。我比我的朋友们过得好还是差？我更开心吗？我更开心吗？他们更开心吗？诸如此类。令人惊讶的是，研究并没有发现人们认为别人的生活更好。他们并没有被朋友们发布的那些快乐的假期和周年纪念照片所欺骗。我们知道，人们在Facebook上发布的大多是积极的事情，而关于他们生活的消极事情则发得比较少。因此，其他研究认为，使用Facebook的用户会认为他们的朋友过着
better lives than they have. So we did not find any support for this argument and we think that maybe people make a collection in their perception and they know that people present a brittle version of themselves. In other words, many people reach the same conclusion that Rachel did. There's always another story. In spite of this, the researchers found that the employees who used Facebook became less happy over time compared to those who were prevented from using Facebook. Being engaged in excessive social comparison decreased one's happiness. So it's not that you think that others are happier than you are, but you need to prove yourself to yourself over and over again and this social comparison engagement makes you
比他们更好的生活。因此，我们没有发现任何支持这一论点的证据，我们认为也许人们在感知上进行了修正，他们知道人们展示的是自己脆弱版本的精修版。换句话说，许多人得出了与蕾切尔相同的结论。总是有另一个故事。尽管如此，研究人员发现，与被禁止使用Facebook的人相比，使用Facebook的员工随着时间的推移变得不那么快乐了。沉迷于过度的社会比较会降低一个人的幸福感。所以，这倒不是说你认为别人比你更幸福，而是你需要一遍又一遍地向自己证明自己，而这种社会比较行为让你变得
less happy. You need to prove yourself to yourself over and over again. In other words, it's not enough for many of us to know we're having a good time. It's not enough to take a beautiful photo, filter it, post it, see how our friends react. We also want our lives to be better, or at least as good, as the lives of our friends. Comparing yourself to others doesn't just steal happiness because you discover that other people seem happier than you are. Comparing yourself to others steals happiness because the very act of comparison takes you out of the life you're living of comparison takes you out of the life
不那么快乐。你需要一遍又一遍地向自己证明自己。换句话说，对我们许多人来说，仅仅知道自己过得开心是不够的。仅仅拍一张漂亮的照片、加个滤镜、发到网上、看看朋友们的反应是不够的。我们还希望我们的生活比朋友们过得更好，或者至少一样好。拿自己和别人作比较并不仅仅是偷走你的快乐，因为你发现别人似乎比你更快乐。拿自己和别人作比较之所以会偷走快乐，是因为比较这一行为本身就把你从你正在经历的生活中抽离了出来，把你在生活
you're living. It takes you out of the moment. The fear that others are leading happier lives than you are has a common nickname. Phomo, the fear of missing out. This particular thing of Phomo for me came from my daughter. My daughter's in her late 20s and I just observed her friends and she experiencing formal and just driving themselves crazy from it. Barbara Khan is a researcher at the University of Pennsylvania who studies perception and
中抽离了出来。它把你从当下抽离了。担心别人过得比你更快乐有一个常见的昵称。错失恐惧症，即害怕错过。对我来说，这种关于错失恐惧症（FOMO）的特殊体验来自于我的女儿。我女儿20多岁，我只是观察她的朋友们和她自己在经历错失恐惧症，并因此把自己折腾得快要发疯。芭芭拉·卡恩是宾夕法尼亚大学的一位研究人员，主要研究感知和
decision-making. She became interested in studying formal after observing a situation with one of her daughter's friends. One of her friends chose to go to a wedding in a beautiful locale instead of going to a beach weekend where the other friends were going to be. And instead of enjoying the wedding that she was at, she was looking at Facebook and looking at the activities of her friends at this beach weekend, which was a routine thing. It wasn't a special occasion at all.
决策制定。在观察了她女儿的一个朋友的情况后，她开始对研究错失恐惧症产生兴趣。她的一个朋友选择去一个风景优美的地方参加婚礼，而不是去其他朋友要去的海滩周末。她没有享受自己所在的婚礼，而是一直在刷Facebook，看着其他朋友在这个海滩周末的活动，而这其实是一个例行公事般的活动。这根本算不上什么特殊场合。
Here's the crucial part. The friend who went to the exotic locale for the wedding didn't think the beach was a better option. She chose to go to the wedding because she felt it was the better choice. Seeing her friends back at the beach didn't make her question her decision, but it did take her mind away from the beautiful spot she was in. I think people make decisions and then formal undermines their enjoyment of the decisions that they've made.
这里是最关键的部分。去异国风情地点参加婚礼的那位朋友并不认为去海滩是更好的选择。她选择去婚礼是因为她觉得这是更好的选择。看到朋友们回到海滩并没有让她对自己的决定产生质疑，但确实让她的心神从她所在的美丽地方飘走了。我认为人们会做出决定，然后错失恐惧症会破坏他们对自己所做决定的享受。
Now, as Barbara can't point out, formal means a lot of different things to different people. It's entirely possible, for example, that the friends who went to the beach vacation were looking at photos from the beautiful destination wedding and feeling like they were the ones who were missing out. But Barbara says the type of formal she ended up focusing on through a series of experiments is a very specific feeling.
现在，正如芭芭拉·卡恩所指出的，错失恐惧症对不同的人意味着许多不同的事情。例如，完全有可能的是，去海滩度假的朋友们当时正在看美丽目的地婚礼的照片，并觉得自己才是错失的那一方。但芭芭拉说，她通过一系列实验最终聚焦的那种错失恐惧症是一种非常具体的感觉。
What we found out from a lot of experiments that we ran, the thing that was generating the formal, the feelings of fear of missing out, it isn't really a fear, it's like a social anxiety, and it's really more about what are your friends doing in building up their social group history that you're missing out on. So it's not really about the experience per se. In all of our experiments, we found that it was really more a function of an anxiety that
我们从开展的大量实验中发现，产生错失恐惧症（FOMO）的事情——那种害怕错失的感觉——其实并不是一种恐惧，它更像是一种社交焦虑，而且它真正关心的其实是：你的朋友们在建立怎样的社交群体历史，而你却错失了。所以它其实并不是关于体验本身的。在我们所有的实验中，我们发现这其实更是一种焦虑功能的体现，即
something might happen in a group experience that will shape the group history in the future, that you may not be part of, and that will undermine your group belongingness. And in fact, when we went back and said, okay, if you could make this decision again, would you choose to go to the beach weekend or to the wedding? Although we didn't use that example in our studies, but that kind of thing, would you choose to go to the clearly better experience, or would you go to the routine thing your friends were doing
群体体验中可能会发生某些事情，从而塑造未来的群体历史，而你可能没有参与其中，这会削弱你的群体归属感。事实上，当我们回过头去问：好吧，如果你能重新做出这个决定，你会选择去海滩周末还是去婚礼？虽然我们在研究中没有使用那个例子，但诸如此类的事情，你会选择去明显更好的体验，还是会去参加朋友们定期都会做
on a regular basis? Almost every time people said, oh no, I'd go to the exotic event. It wasn't that they didn't think that the exotic event was better and the smarter decision, they had no regret about making that decision. What they were anxious about and were using the word anxiety was that maybe something would happen in the group that would forever change the dynamics of the group and they wouldn't have been there when it happened.
的常规活动？几乎每一次，人们都会说：“哦，不，我会去那个异国风情的活动。”并不是他们不认为异国风情的活动更好、是更明智的决定，他们对做出那个决定没有任何遗憾。他们感到焦虑的——并且正在使用“焦虑”这个词——是也许群体中会发生某些事情，永远改变了群体的动态，而事情发生时他们却不在场。
To be sure, envy and social anxiety were not invented by Facebook and Instagram and Snapchat. But Bobber Khan says, these platforms make us much more aware of all the things that are happening without us. She's run a series of experiments each with a couple hundred undergraduates testing the hypothesis that FOMO undermines our happiness
可以肯定的是，嫉妒和社交焦虑并不是由Facebook、Instagram和Snapchat发明的。但芭芭拉·卡恩说，这些平台让我们更加意识到在我们缺席的情况下发生的所有事情。她进行了一系列实验，每场实验都有几百名本科生，用来检验“错失恐惧症会破坏我们对所做决定的快乐感”这一假设。
with the decisions we've made. What I think social media does is it allows you to see these routine things your friends are doing that you really never paid much attention to before. But when you see it on your phone or if you're looking on the tablet or online and you're just observing that your friends are doing something and you're not there, that's something you didn't get to see before. And suddenly you have this pain, oh, I wonder what they're talking about or what's happening, I'm not there. So even if you spend the day, zip lining through the Costa Rican rainforest,
我认为社交媒体的作用是，它让你看到朋友们做的那些你以前从未真正给予太多关注的常规事情。但当你在手机上看到它，或者如果你在平板电脑或网上浏览，只是观察到你的朋友们在做某事而你不在场，那是你以前看不到的东西。突然之间，你感到了这种痛苦：哦，不知道他们在聊什么或者发生了什么，我不在场。所以，即使你花了一天时间，
when you get back to your hotel that night and check Facebook, knowing your friends are having a barbecue and poxy, diminishes some with the pleasure of the zip lining adventure. After seeing the photos of your friends in poxy, Kosorica now seems a little less magical. Fomo, the fear of missing out, leads to actually missing out. Assume you have an opportunity to go to a concert of a musician you love and you never get to see or you get to go to an exotic vacation. And you choose to do that rather than go to a routine barbecue with your friends.
坐着滑索穿过哥斯达黎加的热带雨林，当那天晚上你回到酒店房间检查Facebook，得知你的朋友们正在举行烧烤派对时，这会削弱滑索冒险的一些乐趣。在看到朋友们在派对上的照片后，哥斯达黎加现在看起来似乎没那么神奇了。错失恐惧症（FOMO）会导致真正的错失。假设你有一个机会去看一场你喜爱且从未有机会现场观看的音乐局，或者你可以去异国度假。而你选择这样做，而不是去参加朋友们的常规烧烤派对。
It's exactly set up like that. So we say, assume you do that. Then the experiment is in one condition, we say, now assume while you're on vacation, you pick up your phone and you see your friends enjoying themselves at the barbecue. And in the other condition, which is the control condition, you pick up your phone and you scroll and you look at something, but it's not pictures of your friends.
实验就是完全这样设置的。所以我们说，假设你这样做了。然后实验是，在一种情况下，我们说：现在假设当你在度假时，你拿起手机，看到你的朋友们在烧烤派对上玩得很开心。而在另一种情况下，也就是控制组情况下，你拿起手机滑动并看着某些东西，但那不是你朋友的照片。
And then what we do is before we ask you to look at those pictures, before that manipulation, we measure how much you're enjoying your Hawaii vacation or the exotic concert or whatever. We have you either look at the pictures of your friends or not, and then we measure again how much are you enjoying where you are now. And what we find is a significant decrease in enjoyment when you've looked at the pictures then when you have it. Bob Rakan and her team are doing more experiments, but if their findings hold, they say something really sad about our use of social media.
然后我们做的是，在我们要求你观看那些照片之前，即在那个操纵变量之前，我们测量你有多么享受你的夏威夷假期或异国音乐会或诸如此类的事情。我们让你看朋友们的照片或者不看，然后我们再次测量你现在有多么享受你所在的地方。我们发现，当你看了照片时，你的享受程度会有显著下降，而没看照片时则不会。芭芭拉·卡恩和她的团队正在做更多的实验，但如果他们的发现站得住脚，他们说这揭示了我们使用社交媒体时一个非常悲哀的现象。
The fictional worlds we construct there can make our friends feel their lives are inadequate, and the fictional worlds our friends construct can make our lives feel dollar than they actually are. As for Rachel, she's in a new relationship now and she says she's happy. She has a new job and she and her son are doing well. But she doesn't feel the need to publicize any of this on Facebook. I don't take a lot of pictures anymore. If I'm there in a moment and I'm having that moment, who's the picture for?
我们在那里构建的虚构世界会让我们的朋友觉得他们的生活不够充分，而我们的朋友构建的虚构世界会让我们的生活感觉比实际更加黯淡。至于蕾切尔，她现在有了一段新恋情，她说自己很幸福。她有了一份新工作，她和儿子过得很好。但她觉得没有必要在Facebook上公开这一切。我不再拍很多照片了。如果我当下就在那个时刻并且正在经历那个时刻，这张照片到底是拍给谁看的？
Is it for me to remember or is it, you know, I am trying to live more presently for myself and for my son and just for my own mental well-being. She has asked her new boyfriend not to post about their relationship on social media either. This time, the good moments and the bad will be theirs alone. and the bad will be theirs alone. This week's episode was produced by Maggie Penman, and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Rainer Cohen, and Renee Klar. Our intern is Chloe Connelly.
它是为了让我自己记住，还是，你知道的，我正在努力为我自己、为我的儿子以及仅仅为了我自己的心理健康，更加活在当下。她已经要求她的新男友也不要在社交媒体上发布关于他们感情的事情。这一次，美好的时刻和糟糕的时刻将只属于他们自己。属于他们自己。本期节目由玛吉·彭曼制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、雷纳·科恩和雷妮·克拉尔。我们的实习生是克洛伊·康纳利。
For more hidden brain, follow us on Facebook, Twitter, and Instagram. Actually, hang on a second. Maybe you should take a little break from social media and just listen for my stories each week on your local public radio station. Our unsung hero this week is NPR CEO Yarl Mone. Yarl has a poster in his office that sums up his management philosophy.
想要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们。等等，等一下。也许你应该从社交媒体中抽身休息一会儿，每周只在当地的公共广播电台上听听我的故事。我们本周的无名英雄是NPR首席执行官查尔斯·摩恩。查尔斯在他的办公室里贴了一张海报，总结了他的管理哲学。
It's also his attitude to what life. The poster says, Be kind, Be kind, Be kind. I'm Shankar Vidantum, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这也是他对生活的态度。海报上写着：保持善良，保持善良，保持善良。我是香卡·韦丹坦，这是NPR。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。